Oh
I tend not to be afraid underwater
except of mechanical things that can go
wrong and that has happened a number of
times but the way not to be alarmed is
to rehearse rehearse rehearse you think
in your mind what can go wrong and then
on the rare occasion when it does go
wrong you're ready to react and follow
the procedures that that you've
rehearsed for in your mind and
anticipation that they could have you
run out of air what are you going to do
huh well if you have a buddy you say hey
buddy all right I'd like a breath please
pop and if it's a good buddy they'll
give you some air and that is typically
what does happen and if you have made
the right kind of plan you don't run out
of here where you have a spare you have
enough balance in your tank or a spare
tank to see you through a time that you
anticipate could happen when diving in a
submersible you have a finite amount of
air so you go with a plan to have plenty
of spare air in case something goes
wrong and sometimes things do go wrong
and then you're glad to have that spare
air they have the ability if necessary
to drop weights to come back to the
surface if your other systems of for
some unanticipated reason failed so
people say what but aren't you afraid of
sharks I have to admit that when I first
began diving my heart began to pound a
little bit when I saw the shark because
I've been told sharks are dangerous
they're man-eaters out there you've got
to be careful if you see a shark get out
of the water and at first that's what I
tried to do and then if I realized no
joke man eaters I don't have to worry I
don't qualify they don't attack women no
well they do attack whatever but not but
very rarely and mostly if they've been
provoked what I came to
seen what everybody who has been diving
over the years since the 50s since
diving became accessible to the public
at large and certainly to scientists is
that you're really lucky to see a shark
they're beautiful animals and when you
see a shark or sharks have more happily
lucky to see lots of them that means
that you're in a healthy ocean you're in
an ocean where things are okay have to
be okay to be able to support big
predators like sharks tunas swordfish or
around a coral reef to see groupers and
snappers another predatory fish it means
right you've got a system that's working
so rejoice and don't be afraid you
should be afraid if you go down and
don't see sharks that means the ocean is
in trouble and if the oceans in trouble
we're in trouble